okay let's go next to our caller from
let's go to country code 48 I don't know
what cut what country this is but who's
calling today from country code 48 hi
David
I believe this is me my name is vitaly
yes it is where you coming from
well actually the phone number is
located in Poland but I'm actually
calling from Ukraine how dare you call
from a different place than your phone
number that is horrible
okay now I've been following your show
for a while and the question I have for
you is actually a challenge I would
consider myself to be a progressive like
you and I totally totally agree with you
on pretty much every single issue you
talk about yeah you know respect man
really well thank you what I hear is
amazing yeah but I would say that it's
all pointless and useless if you take
the larger picture like the dying planet
and the point that no one's gonna stop
it voluntarily I mean there's not going
to be a voluntary mmm-hmm sorry
transformation and basically you
basically means that you have to simply
stop the industrial civilization from
destroying the planet there could be a
lot of discussion here of course but I
would love to hear if you're in any way
open to a discussion to have longer to a
deeper discussion in that regard listen
you're presenting a fatalistic but
accurate critique of really of life not
just of my program or programs in
general which is if you really want a
big picture it we're all dead the Sun is
eventually going to expand and engulf
the earth and if Homo sapiens has not
found some other place to live
Homo sapiens will die out I mean I'm
taking it to them taking the fatalism to
a saw
extreme-right vitaliy but there's a
point to this so then we come back to
any one activist or any one show I mean
yeah you're right there are in modern
American and sort of global society a
few major meta issues you've identified
one which is climate change in the
destruction of the planet in order to
make change happen in a serious way we
need to change the way that politics is
financed and controlled by the rich and
by corporations that's another meta
issue we need to change how it is that
we select our leaders you know there's
these sort of three or four meta issues
that exist and if we don't deal with
them then we're kind of doomed but but I
think that that's what we're trying to
do I mean we talk about these issues on
our show and your how you're obviously
right that if those issues aren't dealt
with we're in trouble
but I don't know that that gets us to a
point of why even bother I don't it
doesn't get me to why even bother no I
I'm what I'm saying is that why even
bother you know creating democracy if
that doesn't give us enough time to
actually secure a future for the coming
generation this proper you know the next
generation not eventually not when the
Sun burns out not not that I'm talking
about the kids that are being born today
they will not basically live to die that
that's pretty much a guarantee for
almost every one of them because you
know you see what's happening with
hurricanes you see what's happening with
extreme heat waves you see what's
happening with the food supply with the
immigration with you know quite a lot of
stuff and that's all because we burn
fossil fuels and what I'm saying you're
I believe you're taking it wrong like
you're you see there's fatalistic or
something I'm trying to say that any
ambition that does not take into account
the bigger picture is basically
pointless
okay well listen that's your point then
I agree with you I agree that the bigger
picture has to be taken into account
this is why I talk all the time about
the unsustainability of the idea of
infinite and indefinite growth as it is
considered economically I mean in in
that as you're laying it out vitaly I
agree with you ok I hope I'll be writing
to you on Twitter and while proposing
probably some public dialog in that I
would be sort of your friendly rival if
you wanted that ok well it sounds like
we agreed so it may not be it may not be
the most exciting rivalry but I welcome
your comments Batali thank you I've got
a bunch of people holding so I'm going
to continue moving down the queue